المعركه على بخمو التكاد تكون من اكثر
المعارك ضراوطا منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا لا يمكن معرفه الخسائر لدى
الجانبين على نحو دقيق فروسيا واوكرانيا
لا تتحدثان سوى عن السيطره على بخموت او
الاحتفاظ بها
اوكرانيا دفعت الى المعركه بنخبه من
قواتها المقاتله يتمركز فيها مقاتلون لواء
الثالث والتسعين ومقاتلون من كتيبه ازوف
بينما يقاتل جنود اللواء الثاني والتسعين
في مناطق محاذيه لابقاء القوات الروسيه
منشغله اما من الجانب الروسي فتقود
ميليشيا فاجنر الهجوم على المدينه بدلا من
الجيش الروسي
في الشكل يقترب حجم الدمار هنا ليشبه دمار
ستالينغراد في الحرب العالميه الثانيه لكن
بخموت التي لا تزيد مساحتها على 41
كيلومترا مربعا لا تقارن باهميه
ستالينغراد استراتيجيا ولا بمساحتها التي
تزيد على
859 كيلومترا مربعا
فلماذا يستمر القتال بين الروس
والاوكرانيين في باخموت منذ ثمانيه اشهر
هي قلعه لمعنويتنا هكذا وصف الرئيس
الاوكراني المدينه وصف يكاد يقترب من
اسباب استمرار القتال
لن نسلم باخموت سنقاتل طالما امكننا ذلك
باخ مت قلعتنا ومن ماتوا فيها نعتبرهم
ابطالا واذا تسلمنا اسلحه بعيده المدى فلن
ننسحب من بخمس وسنبدا باستعاده دومباس
فباخمت لتحمل اي اهميه استراتيجيه في
الحرب بشكل عام والانسحاب منها في الحاله
الاوكرانيه لا يفرض واقعا جديدا بحسب وزير
الدفاع الامريكي بالنسبه لروسيا فان
الامساك بباخ نوت يزيد من مساحه سيطرتها
على اقليم الدومباس التي ضمته الى اراضيها
وقد يتيح لها التقدم او على الاقل تامين
الطريق للتقدم باتجاه سلافيان
تقدم لن يكون سهلا على ايه حال نظرا
لتضاريس المنطقه
ولهذا فان الاهميه التي تحملها معركه
بخموت ليست ميدانيه بحته
كيف حولت بخموت الى رمز للمقاومه لترسل من
وراء القتال رساله ان الدعم الغربي يمكنها
من صد الهجمات الروسيه
وروسيا تريد نصرا معنويا بعد اشهر من
الجنود الميداني حتى لو كان الفصل شتاء
من الناحيه القانونيه سيطرنا على بخموت
وسيتولى القاده الذين حققوا هذا التقدم
رفع هذه الاعلام اعلى ميفاجنر وحتى لو كان
نصرا ممهورا بتوقيع فاجنر